Let's go to our caller from the seven one
eight area code.
Who's calling today from seven one eight?
Yeah.
What's up?
Is Derrick in Brooklyn?
Danny from Brooklyn.
What neighborhood in Brooklyn?
Bay Ridge, Bay Ridge, that is a that is a
state is one of the top neighborhoods, I would
say.
Yeah, oh, I guess so.
All right.
Well, you're not thrilled about Bay Ridge,
but what's on your mind today?
I was very right leaning.
So that's true.
Me the downside of it.
Well, my question is.
So, April, when Trump leaves office.
I'm not going.
Not going to be silent, like either as president
or appropriate in that way.
Again, news.
He'll be on Fox News every morning.
And Sean Hannity.
Oh, and so what kind of impact do you believe
this will have on society?
You believe it will be like having two presidents?
Well, they will listen to his command.
That's a good question.
Or, um.
Yeah.
So imagine so.
So you're saying Biden wins and Trump loses
whatever the hell Trump does between November
3rd and January 20th.
Eventually, Trump leaves and Biden is the
actual president.
But Trump continues to tweet and he continues
to be in Brightman's.
You're saying beyond that, Trump continues
to tweet and be interviewed and say, here's
what I would be doing here is which would
should be doing?
Will he have enough followers?
Were him running almost like a parallel presidency?
Could have an impact.
Exactly.
I honestly, I want it's possible and it's
very scary.
It's very scary, the idea, because I think
that, you know, 60 plus million people are
going to vote for the guy.
And if he sort of never really leaves the
public eye the way George W. Bush did in the
immediate aftermath of his presidency, the
way Barack Obama did for a time after his
presidency, it could wreak absolute and total
havoc.
Yeah, so that's interesting.
But you know what?
I'm okay dealing with that problem when we
get to it.
As long as we remove him.
OK.
Yeah, it's just, you know, I'm just thinking,
you know, because I don't imagine him being
done with, like, Barack Obama or George W.
Bush.
No, I'm 90 percent with you.
I think there's 10 percent of me that thinks
maybe because Trump's this huge narcissist,
it's possible Trump, if he loses, will say,
I didn't want a second term anyway and I don't
want anything to do with politics anyway.
And we never hear from him again.
I think that's like a one in 10.
I think the nine and ten is what exactly what
you're talking about, which is he won't shut
up.
Got it.
All right.
Do let me film it.
Thank you.
All right.
Say hi to everybody in Brooklyn for me.
I miss Miss Living in Brooklyn.
Brooklyn's Great Gister.
Just a great place.